[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten mit namens
russlands präsident putin kriegsherr der
russischen angreifer in der ukraine hat
einen ersten sieg erklärt die seit
wochen belagerte stadt mariupol sei nun
befreit es liegt in diesem wort allein
der ganze abgrund und wahnsinn dieses
krieges die wahrheit ist mario pollich
liegt in schutt und asche
hunderttausende menschen sind vertrieben
zehntausende so die schätzungen getötet
dem rest droht nun blockade und das
aushungern die ukrainische regierung
will mario pohl noch nicht verloren
geben und setzt auf waffen aus dem
westen us präsident biden sagte weitere
militärhilfe zu christian von rechenberg
so sie triumph auf russisch aus ein
panzer in mariupol bild zeigen wer hier
der boss ist ein kinderspiel dieser
krieg soll das wohl heißen und es hat
wohl mit dem zu tun was putin seinen
verteidigungsminister heute verkünden
ließ
ganz mario pohl ist in der hand der
russischen streitkräfte
mario puls bürgermeister bestreitet das
und auch die ukrainischen kämpfern im
belagerten stahlwerk haben noch nicht
aufgegeben in unterzahl zwar aber nicht
zu unterschätzen putin reagiert
der wolke sieben sturm auf das werk ist
unnötig ich befehle ihn zu stoppen
blockieren sie die anlage stattdessen so
dass da keine fliege mehr rauskommt
ein zeichen der schwäche so deutet es
die ukraine die angriffe gehen weiter
vernichten das wenige was in mario pohl
noch zum leben blieb russische
kriegsreporter zeigen solche bilder von
evakuierungen ob heute menschen aus der
stadt heraus kamen ist unklar
mehr als 1000 ziele habe man heute in
der ukraine angegriffen erklärt
russlands militär
der feind versucht seine angriffe im
osten der ukraine zu verstärken um die
gebiete don jetzt und lohans vollständig
unter seine kontrolle zu bringen
die ukraine zählt ihre opfer nördlich
der hauptstadt kiew im vorort borodjanka
sind heute womöglich neu hinzugekommen
zivilisten heißt dass frauen kinder
gefunden in zwei gräbern in der ganzen
region kiew zähle man mehr als 1000 tote
zivilisten dem sterben können sie auch
in maribor nichts entgegensetzen
russisches fernsehen will hier die
folgen eines ukrainischen angriffs auf
ein krankenhaus zeigen ob es stimmt oder
nicht mag denen egal sein die hier keine
hilfe mehr finden
unsere bedingungen sind katastrophal
medizin die wir zusammen sammeln konnten
hier liegt ihr um
katastrophal wie die lage der kämpfer im
stahlwerk putins taktik scheint klar er
will sie aushungern
axel starben in moskau putin braucht
offensichtlich erfolgsmeldungen und
meldet die eroberung die aber ja nicht
vollständig ist wie wichtig ist für ihn
dieses symbol mario pohl
naja mario police vor allen dingen ein
symbol es wäre ein erfolg den man hier
zu hause als großen sieg als großen
triumph verkaufen könnte es gab ja zu
beginn dieser militärischen
spezialoperation wie sie hier im land
heißen muss drei szenarien die von
strategen diskutiert wurden szenarien
nummer eins komplette machtübernahme
also operationen im ganzen land
szenarien nummer zwei die de facto
teilung der ukraine an entlang des
flusses und
szenarien nummer drei der osten der
ukraine dass der donbass und die
landbrücke herunterzukommen das ist also
das szenario worauf ist offenbar
hinausläuft und wie wir alle wissen
schleppt sich diese militär operation
sehr lange hin und der kreml wartet
natürlich auf eine erfolgsmeldung
besonders weil der 19 mai vor der tür
steht der tag an dem russland
traditionsgemäß den seinen helden des
zweiten weltkriegs bedenkt da käme ein
solcher erfolg ganz zu passen axel sturm
in moskau dankeschön
die lage in mariupol macht die
dringlichkeit der ukraine bei der
verteidigung mit waffen zu helfen
augenfällig auch deutschland hilft die
bundesregierung ist bei der diskussion
um art und umfang der lieferungen aber
dabei in eine ampel krise zu rutschen
kanzler scholz bekommt den unmut nicht
eingefangen und seine linie nicht klar
vermittelt erst jetzt zwei tage nach
seiner erklärung setzt sich das wort
ringtausch durch um deutlich zu machen
wir verweigern uns nicht sondern helfen
damit andere helfen kritik und zweifel
an der deutschen rolle gibt es längst
auch auf europäischer ebene wie flo
erneuern aus brüssel berichtet
beinahe schon ist es keine nachricht
mehr keine mit seltenheitswert zumindest
das auch heute in kiew regierungschefs
aus der eu eintreffen er aus spanien sie
aus dänemark wer heute nicht kommt ist
der aus deutschland wer weiß ob olaf
scholz in der ukraine überhaupt etwas zu
gewinnen hätte während die kritik
international immer schärfer wird nur
zwei beispiele ein renommierter
us-historiker wirft deutschland vor mit
seiner politik russischen faschismus zu
finanzieren und eine ehemalige polnische
premierministerin schreibt deutschland
verletze die solidarität in eu und nato
ohne frage zugespitzt aber keine
einzelmeinungen
insgesamt fragt man sich
was deutschland machen würde wenn
russland weit
über die ukraine mit diesem krieg
hinausgeht und
schlussfolgerungen sie gezogen werden
von dieser zögerliche deutsche politik
sind halt nicht ermutigen tatsächlich
wirkt es nach außen so als hinke die
bundesregierung stets hinterher handel
erst wenn der druck von außen zu groß
wird ob beim stopp von nord stream 2 bei
einem embargo russischer kohle oder eben
bei waffenlieferungen
dabei liefert deutschland nicht etwa
weniger waffen als vergleichbare länder
wie frankreich und verspricht heute
sogar in einem ringtausch die eigenen
marder kampfpanzer dem nato partner
sowie in jenen bereitzustellen damit
slowenien wiederum solche panzer
sowjetischer bauart richtung ukraine
schicken kann dieser ringtausch würde
gewährleisten dass schnell geliefert
werden kann und vor allem ohne
erforderliche ausbildungszeiten das ist
das was die ukraine jetzt braucht an die
vermeintliche führung nation aber stellt
europa höhere ansprüche als an andere
und dem landwirt seine vergangenheit auf
die füße die zu engen beziehungen mit
moskau und manche haltung die schon
damals stark kritisiert wurde etwa in
der griechenland krise meint ein
ehemaliger französischer top diplomat
damals hat deutschland stets erklärt
regeln sind regeln und wenn ihr fehler
gemacht habt müsst ihr dafür bezahlen
nun deutschland hat im energiebereich
große fehler gemacht oder jetzt haben
viele eu-staaten den eindruck dass
deutschland nicht nach denselben regeln
spielen will die es anderen auffällig
tat wie damals die schwarze null
neben den handlungen sehen in der
politik auch die bilder solche wie diese
heute mit zwei eu-regierungschefs in der
ukraine über entsprechende reisepläne
von olaf scholz ist derzeit nichts
bekannt
ja es geht um bilder auch um die kritik
in der sache da lohnt die nachfrage an
florian in brüssel florian ist es vor
allem ein vermittlungsproblem dass die
bundesregierung und kanzler scholz da
hat auch in brüssel
vor allem das wäre mir jetzt etwas zu
hoch gegriffen aber es gibt dieses
kommunikationsproblem der
bundesregierung auch hier immer
offensichtlicher auf der europäischen
bühne da erleben wir hier und die
europäischen partner erleben hier auf
der europäischen bühne die
außenministerin von den grünen frau
baerbock die ja sehr viel offensiver
kommuniziert als etwa ihre spd kollegin
vom verteidigungsressort christine
lambrecht und es gibt eben den spd
bundeskanzler scholz der jahr vorsichtig
formuliert doch sehr zurückhaltend sich
äußert und auch nicht immer klar
formuliert und das führt dann doch zu
einer gewissen verwirrung so sehr dass
manche hier auch in
hintergrundgesprächen etwa die deutschen
journalisten fragen was denn nun
eigentlich die aktuelle position der
berliner bundesregierung der sache in
sachen waffenlieferungen eigentlich sei
deutschland hat in dieser krise nicht
die führungsrolle die es in früheren
krisen einmal hatte das liegt zum einen
sicherlich auch an den inhalten den
vielen dossiers steht berlin eben auf
der bremse vor allem im bereich energie
aber es liegt eben sicherlich auch zu
einem guten teil an der kommunikation
die eben etwas verwirrend ist und steht
damit unter druck aber ist die kritik
wirklich so einhellig
ich würde sagen auch da täuscht der
eindruck etwas weil die kritik natürlich
sehr lautstark sehr offensiv vorgetragen
wird und deshalb naturgemäß auch in der
öffentlichkeit in den medien an sehr
sehr viel größeren raum erhält als es
vielleicht angebracht wäre in der tat
gibt es manche länder die sich hier auch
in den letzten tagen von der deutschen
position noch entfernt haben ganz
aktuell die niederlande die etwa vor
zwei tagen gesagt haben dass sie jetzt
auch schweres gerät direkt in die
ukraine liefern werden aber andere tun
das eben nicht als ein beispiel gerade
auch im beitrag kurz angesprochen
frankreich hat präsident makro hier in
brüssel vor drei wochen ganz klar gesagt
die lieferung von panzern das sei seine
persönliche rote linie und daran hat
sich auch bis jetzt nichts geändert aber
rundum frankreich gibt es keine
vergleichbaren debatten wie rund um
deutschland und das wiederum meines
erachtens auch an der sehr viel klareren
kommunikation die die französische
regierung hat im vergleich zu der
regierung aus berlin danke für die
einschätzung florian hahn aus brüssel
und wir werfen noch ein blick in die
ukrainische hauptstadt kiew wurde gegen
die russische armee erfolgreich
verteidigt putins truppen verübten
schrecklichen gräueltaten in den
vororten einnehmen konnten sie die stadt
nach wochen nicht und zogen ab ein
sicherer ort ist kiew damit nicht
bürgermeister klitschko warnte heute vor
der rückkehr in die stadt die jeder zeit
angegriffen werden könne auch minen
sprengfallen und zurückgelassene
munition sind eine gefahr und müssen
geräumt werden wie dominik löschmeister
aus kiew berichtet
die müsst noch muss schon zurückgekehrt
1 800 einwohner dorf vor den toren
schossen die russischen truppen sind
abgezogen zurück bleiben zerstörung und
minen das macht die rückkehr
lebensgefährlich ich habe ein seil mit
einem haken genutzt man muss es werfen
und über den boden fiel wer nichts
explodiert kann man gehen
granaten raketen und blindgänger
vielerorts in den zerstörten vororten
von kiew findet man die
hinterlassenschaften des krieges
vorsicht minen steht auf diesem schild
nach ukrainischen angaben haben die
russischen angreifer auch sprengfallen
zurückgelassen das vorgehen habe system
berichtet und sein ukrainischer soldat
sie legen ringe schmuck und halsketten
als spreng vor allem aus sie graben ein
loch darunter und legen dort sprengstoff
hinein dasselbe gilt für kinderspielzeug
und die leichen ihrer eigenen soldaten
der kampfmittelräumdienst der käfer
polizei sammelt jeden tag minen und
sprengkörper 1 diese sandgrube außerhalb
von kiew bringen sie das explosive
material um es später kontrolliert zu
sprengen
normalerweise arbeiten wir nach anrufen
von der bevölkerung aber wenn wir die
informationen haben dass der feind in
einem gebiet gewesen ist
aktiv dort himmel
nach un angaben ist die ukraine ohnehin
eines der am stärksten durch minen
belasteten länder der welt durch den
krieg bombast ihr seid 2014 läuft die
russische angriffskrieg wird das problem
größer machen
aus meiner erfahrung kann ich sagen dass
ein jahr krieg zehn jahre minenräumung
bedeutet also brauchen wir nach diesem
kriegs monat in kiew mindestens ein jahr
für die räumung der mine sammelt oder
es ist ein gefährlicher job erst am
wochenende starben drei junge
bombenentschärfer an diesem nachmittag
geht alles gut mit der sprengung
mehr zur lage in der ukraine und ein
gespräch zur strategischen bedeutung von
mario pohl später im heute-journal
update mit fragen an christian welling
von der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik und nun weitere
nachrichten gundula gause nach neuen
zahlen der un-organisation für migration
sind in der ukraine wegen des krieges
mehr als 7,7 millionen menschen auf der
flucht weitere fünf millionen ukraine
haben ihre heimat verlassen in diesen
tagen zieht es aber auch tausende zurück
in die ukraine sie nehmen die riskante
reise auf sich wollen in ihrer heimat
den kampf gegen die russischen angreifer
unterstützen außerdem steht das
orthodoxe osterfest an für viele ein
wichtiger grund nach hause zu wollen
trotz aller gefahren
und wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
oder auf der flucht helfen wollen dann
können sie das mit einer spende an das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
spenden konto de 65 104 106 100 104 106
100 stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine
weitere informationen auf zdf.de
auf dem tempelberg in jerusalem ist es
erneut zu zusammenstößen zwischen
palästinensern und der israelischen
polizei gekommen steine flogen muslime
verbarrikadierten sich die lage an der
heiligen stätte ist seit tagen
angespannt zudem haben auch in der
vergangenen nacht militante
palästinenser raketen aus dem
gazastreifen in richtung israel
abgeschossen darauf reagierte die
israelische luftwaffe mit angriffen auf
ziele der hamas im gazastreifen
auch in afghanistan nimmt die gewalt
wieder zu bei anschlägen in mehreren
großstädten sind mindestens 28 menschen
getötet worden dutzende wurden bei
explosionen in kabul und in kundus
verletzt
ein bombenanschlag zur gebetszeit auf
eine moschee in masar i scharif forderte
allein 20 opfer terrorexperten machen
sunnitische
extremisten verantwortlich die andere
muslime als abtrünnige betrachten
vor der stichwahl um die präsidentschaft
in frankreich am sonntag kämpfen
amtsinhaber max und konkurrentin lippen
um stimmen der unentschlossenen vor
allem im linken lager das tv-duell
verfolgten fast 16 millionen menschen in
einer ungewöhnlichen aktion haben
bundeskanzler scholz und die
regierungschefs von spanien und portugal
sanchez und costa gemeinsam zur
wiederwahl von makro aufgerufen ohne
seinen namen zu nennen europa brauche
ein frankreich das für die gemeinsamen
werte einstehen
die linkspartei in deutschland will sich
nach dem rücktritt der co-vorsitzenden
hennig will zu nach sexismus vorwürfen
und wahlniederlagen personell und
inhaltlich neu aufstellen janine wissler
soll zunächst allein die partei führen
über den vorstand soll auf dem parteitag
im juni entschieden werden die sexismus
vorwürfe will die linke mit unabhängigen
und externen beratern aufarbeiten
das frühjahr 22 markiert für deutschland
eine historische zäsur nach
jahrhunderten ist laut einer
hochrechnung weniger als die hälfte der
bevölkerung noch mitglied in der
evangelischen oder katholischen kirche
eine entwicklung die beschleunigt wurde
durch die zuletzt hohe zahl von
kirchenaustritten
in der katholischen kirche hat das
missbrauchs gutachten der erzdiözese
münchen für einen sprunghaften anstieg
der austritte geführt auch die stocken
der aufklärung in köln und die rolle des
kardinals rainer woelki lösten geradezu
eine welle von austritten aus das dürfte
so weitergehen denn das erzbistum köln
kommt nicht aus den schlagzeilen jetzt
geht es um eine millionen schuld eines
priesters und um die wenig transparente
finanzspritze für eine hochschule heiko
rahmens und ina baltes bericht
die hochschule für katholische theologie
ein prestige objekt des kölner kardinal
woelki frisch renoviert ein großes
gebäude für 80 studenten die priester
werden wollen nach den vorstellungen
woelkis und nicht nach dem lehrplan
einer staatlichen liberaleren
universität die jährlichen kosten haben
sich inzwischen knapp verdreifacht
bezahlt aus einem fonds für besondere
bedürfnisse dem sogenannten bbv eigens
für den kardinal gespeist auszahlungen
von priestern
das ist ganz klar ein lieblingsprojekt
von woelki wo er auch dann bereit war
eben millionensummen aus diesem bbv zu
seinen zu seiner verfügung für besondere
bedürfnisse
des bistums zu investieren im vorlagen
2020 rund 17 millionen euro davon wurden
die teuren missbrauchs gutachten krisen
pr und entschädigungen für die
missbrauchsopfer bezahlt dazu die kosten
für woelkis hochschule jährlich rund 3,2
millionen euro geld der kirche ist ja
nie geld des bischofs alles vermögen was
die kirche hat ist letztlich das geld
der gläubigen deswegen ja auch die
interne kontrolle und aufsicht also der
bischof kann niemals geld ausgeben als
wäre das sein eigenes
große ausgaben aus dem fonds sind
genehmigungspflichtig doch nun wurde
bekannt das erzbistum sprang auch für
schulden eines priesters ein zahlte
insgesamt über eine million euro und hat
sich diese ausgabe nicht genehmigen
lassen dazu meint das erzbistum zitat
die rechtliche überprüfung des
sachverhalts hat ergeben dass die
voraussetzungen für eine gremien
beteiligung nicht vorlag
aus dem gleichen topf werden auch die
missbrauchs opfer entschädigt
durchschnittlich mit rund 20.000 euro
für das erzbistum sei die entschädigung
des priesters ein unvergleichbarer
einzelfall der sich heute so nicht
wiederholen würde ein kirchenrechtler
fordert konsequenzen der umgang mit
diesem sondervermögen ist absolut
willkürlich intransparent und man kann
nicht nachvollziehen nach welchen
kriterien welche dritte mit geldern
begünstigt werden es ist höchste zeit
dass dieses verhalten unabhängig
aufgearbeitet und aufgeklärt wird und
dann möglicherweise die rechtlichen
konsequenzen zu ziehen sind für die
kaliber ein zeichen für weiterhin
schlechtes krisenmanagement
und das schadet nicht nur dem erzbistum
sondern der gesamten katholischen kirche
die deutsche ampel regierung hat sich im
vergangenen jahr einen ehrgeizigen
reformplan geschrieben ziele unter
anderem eine energiewende und eine
agrarwende aber das war vor der
zeitenwende und dem krieg in der ukraine
passt nun auch das eine zum anderen ja
sagt zum beispiel der finanzminister
christian lindner der erneuerbare
energien nun schon zu freiheits energien
adelt weil sie die abhängigkeit von
russland reduzieren und bei der
landwirtschaft der krieg führt zu
getreide mangel eigentlich müsste nun
mehr angebaut werden aber das sieht die
agrarwende er nicht vor über die
deutschen bauern in der zeitenwende
stefan kech die preise explodieren für
alles was bauern brauchen lieferketten
reißen fachkräfte fehlen die
umstrukturierung der landwirtschaft ist
in vollem gange hans uwe heilmann will
seinen betrieb noch unabhängiger machen
von lieferengpässen und energiekrisen
sie erzeugen das meiste futter selbst
haben solardächer auf den ställen und
eine biogasanlage
das ganz einfach dass wir uns von den
hohen energiepreisen am markt abkoppeln
wir haben wir rechnen hier mit deutlich
niedrigeren preisen wenn wir uns alltag
versorgen bauer heimann hat futter und
dünger im letzten jahr noch zu alten
preisen eingekauft einen vorteil für den
moment doch in diesem jahr muss er
wieder einkaufen die mehrkosten wird er
weitergeben müssen die politische
forderung nach mehr bio in der
landwirtschaft findet heilmann
angesichts der aktuellen krisen absurd
die forderung an der landwirtschaft 20
prozent bio umzustellen ist es von
politikern schon heute gibt es mehr bio
milch am markt viele landwirte die
umgestellt werden ihre bio milch nicht
löst angesichts von krisen kriege und
klimawandel wird diskutiert ob
stillgelegte flächen jetzt vielleicht
doch für futter und lebensmittel
umgelagert werden sollten nein sagt der
sächsische landwirtschaftsminister da
geht es darum dass vier prozent der
fläche tatsächlich rückzugsräume für die
natur sein sollen und das ganze eben
auch langfristig weiß rückzugsräume
gerade insekten sind die braucht man für
bodenfruchtbarkeit die braucht man für
viele öko dem system die bestäuber
leistung noch mit flächenstilllegungen
für die sekten hadern selbst biobauern
axel heinze ist einer von ihnen seit 21
jahren bio bauer mit leib und seele dass
er angesichts des krieges ackerfläche
unbewirtschaftete lassen soll das geht
ihm nicht in den kopf das ist absolut 19
zumal wir als bio betriebe sowieso schon
viel für bodenfruchtbarkeit für
artenvielfalt für biodiversität das
sehen wir total unterwegs das ist unser
anliegen
preissteigerungen abhängigkeiten
rohstoffmangel stellen die landwirte vor
völlig neue fragen regionale kreisläufe
lokale wertschöpfung könnten die antwort
sein
wir werden uns dieser herausforderung
stellen müssen so oder so alle egal
konventioneller bio wir stellen uns
dieser herausforderung was wir nicht
machen dürfen ins jammertal verfallen
und sagen jetzt ist alles mist und jetzt
alles schlecht sondern köpfe
zusammenstecken genug reagieren heinze
sagt der landwirtschaft gehe es wieder
hummel von der sage man dass sie
eigentlich gar nicht fliegen können
dürfte aber sie kann es doch bauern
seien auch so fänden für alles eine
lösung auch wenn es erstmal unmöglich
scheint
und um die verbraucher zu entlasten
allemal diejenigen mit geringeren
einkommen fordern sozialverbände ein
neues nachdenken über eine abschaffung
der mehrwertsteuer für obst und gemüse
frank bethmann wie sinnvoll ist das aus
sicht von wirtschaftsexperten ja darüber
wurde heute teilweise hitzig und sehr
kontrovers diskutiert würden sich alle
einig waren lebensmittel dürfen nicht
zum luxusgut werden aber während die
einen wie maße fritzsche vom diw sagen
ja man sollte das tempo her durchaus
machen sind andere darin nicht die
lösung mit einer mehrwertsteuersenkung
würden auch die haushalte begünstigt die
sich die steigenden preise leisten
könnten sagt beispielsweise der
handelsverband deutschland
stattdessen sollte die bundesregierung
die staatlichen transfers damit sind
sozialleistungen gemeint entsprechend
erhöhen und gegebenenfalls bei ihrem
leistungspaket entsprechend nachbessern
einer der derzeit trotz gestiegener
kosten für rohstoffe und energie gut
verdient ist nestlé dem
lebensmittelriesen das zeigen die
aktuellen geschäftszahlen gelingt ist
die steigenden preise an die verbraucher
weiterzugeben und will das auch künftig
machen wie konzernchef mark schneider
heute betonte die kosteninflation steigt
weiterhin kräftig an weshalb im verlauf
des jahres weitere preisanpassungen
erforderlich sein werden was wiederum
edeka chef markus mosa heute erboste er
warnte bei der vorlage der eigenen
bilanz nestlé und co vor überzogenen
preisforderungen eine wichtige stimme
allerdings fehlt noch die von
finanzminister christian lindner er hat
sich zu einer möglichen
mehrwertsteuersenkung noch nicht
geäußert wir werden berichten frank
bethmann vielen dank
das zdf trauert um hans janke unser
langjähriger fernsehspielchef und
stellvertretender programmdirektor ist
im alter von 77 jahren in wiesbaden
gestorben ein garant für höchste
filmqualität im zdf so würdigte
intendant norbert himmler den allseits
geschätzten kollegen janka erfand die
marke fernsehfilm der woche und
entwickelte erfolgreiche freitags krimis
wie derrick der alte und ein fall für
zwei
die kunstbiennale in venedig ist ab dem
wochenende zu besuchen verschoben wegen
der pandemie steht sie nun auch im
zeichen des ukraine krieges so fördert
die biennale künstler aus der ukraine
wie den vor dem krieg geflüchteten
zeichner und bildhauer paloma kopf der
seinen brunnen der erschöpfung zeigt der
russische pavillon bleibt leer die
russischen künstler zogen freiwillig
zurück spektakuläre kunst installationen
fordern mehr menschlichkeit ein
so eine meldung haben wir noch für sie
an diesem 21 april es gab auch etwas zu
feiern den 96 geburtstag von queen
elizabeth ein ständchen vor schloss
windsor
noonan schüsse in london würdigung für
die älteste und dienstälteste monarchien
des britischen königreichs allerdings in
abwesenheit das bild des tages die queen
zwischen zwei ihrer schneeweißen ponys
ihre begeisterung für pferde ist auch
mit 96 und gebrochen die queen
verbrachte ihren ehrentag zurückgezogen
auf ihrem landsitz sandringham offiziell
gefeiert wird wie üblich im juni und
dann sind die pferdchen auch wieder gut
gefüllt so damit verabschieden wir uns
verweisen auch auf die runde bei maybrit
illner unter anderem mit sigmar gabriel
die putins offensive und deutschlands
defensive haltung diskutiert und um 0.30
meldet sich nah sagte mir mit unserem
heute-journal update typischen abend
[Musik]
guten abend an der wetterlage ändert
sich wirklich wenig das hoch hier
zwischen skandinavien und island bleibt
da einfach kleben und so haben wir es
immer noch mit einer nordöstlichen
strömung zu tun sie sehen wie hier die
kaltluft herumgeführt wird über
skandinavien und das baltikum bis nach
mitteleuropa
so legen morgen die höchsttemperaturen
zwischen dem nordkap und dem alpenrand
nur so bei 5 bis 15 grad und ähnlich
kühl ist es auch morgen noch mal in
spanien mit 10 bis 15 grad was dagegen
in frankreich und am mittelmeer
besonders am östlichen mittelmeer die
kommende nacht wird etwas bilder seien
als die vergangenen bis auf neun grad
sinken die temperaturen hier am
niederrhein am alpenrand geht es bis 0
grad runter klar ist der himmel
eigentlich nur ganz im norden und ganz
im süden sonst gibt es viele wolken und
ab und zu kann es auch noch mal ein
bisschen regnen und morgen bleibt es
total in norddeutschland rüb hier
zwischen der oder und dem thüringer wald
da kann es auch immer noch ein bisschen
regnen strahlenden sonnenschein sehen
sie dagegen zum beispiel über sylt oder
auch in nordfriesland und richtung
saarland südliches rheinland pfalz am
oberrhein und richtung bodensee richtung
osten sind die wolken etwas dichter so
wird es morgen zwischen dem mittel und
dem oberrhein am wärmsten
da klettern die temperaturen auf 19 bis
20 grad sonst sind es 16 bis 18 grad und
kälter ist es im nordosten bei 11 bis 15
grad am samstag gibt es schon die ersten
regenschauer am alpenrand schauer und
gewitter breiten sich dann weiter
richtung klein bis mitte aus guten abend